un espectáculo extraño para los testigos
pero un problema más grave para el
fabricante de aviones boeing ha
recomendado detener los vuelos de
ciertos aviones 777 después de que los
escombros del mismo tipo de avión
cayeran sobre la ciudad de denver el
sábado su motor falló poco después del
despegue recomendamos y apoyamos la
suspensión de las operaciones de los 69
27 77 en servicio y los 59 en
almacenamiento que son propulsados por
motores pratt and whitney 4000 112
mientras la investigación de la junta
nacional de seguridad en el transporte
está en curso
el vuelo 328 se dirigía a honolulu con
241 personas a bordo cuando falló su
motor derecho pudo dar la vuelta y
aterrizar de forma segura y no se
reportaron heridos ni a bordo ni en
tierra con los peores 20 minutos
solamente estaba rezando y dije esto no
puede ser el anuncio de boeing se
produjo horas después de que el
organismo de aviación de eeuu ordenará
inspecciones adicionales a aviones
boeing 777 con el mismo motor que el del
vuelo 320
mientras tanto el ministerio de
transporte de japón ordenó a japan
airlines y anna suspender los vuelos de
aviones boeing 777 hasta nuevo aviso un
llamado al que se sumaron las dos
principales aerolíneas surcoreanas el
incidente supone un nuevo golpe para
boeing el 737 max del fabricante quedó
en tierra en todo el mundo en marzo de
2019 después de que 346 personas
murieran en dos accidentes debido a un
sistema de manejo de vuelo defectuoso